pierre bédier en déplacement dans le
canton de rambouillet le président
sortant du département des yvelines est
venu rencontrer le duo clarisse de mon
geoffroy backs de keating candidats au
départemental
ils se sont retrouvés au vaccinodromes
de rambouillet salle patenôtre ce rendez
vous a également permis de constater le
déploiement du dispositif ou yes plus
sur le site
cinq jeunes sont concernés sur le centre
de vaccination ce dispositif a prospéré
et nous l'avons réactiver et
intensifiées à l'occasion de la pandémie
dont mise à disposition de jeunes en
recherche d'emploi ou de jeunes
étudiants mise à disposition des
collectivités pour qu'ils participent à
l'origine c'était vaincre la solitude
des personnes âgées en période estivale
et là c'est l'accompagnement de toutes
les personnes d'enjeux processus de
vaccination dans la matinée pierre
bédier également campagne pour sa
réélection et le binôme e clarisse de
montréjeau fera backs de keating se sont
rendus dans les locaux de la gendarmerie
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines un site
rénové à hauteur de 225 mille euros par
le département les gendarmes ne sont pas
sous notre responsabilité
mais les bâtiments de la gendarmerie de
leçon donc je venais vérifier là
effectivement que les travaux qui
avaient été programmées convenait
répondait bien aux attentes de ces
gendarmes
c'est le cas et j'en suis ravi parce que
si on veut avoir une sécurité
cette marche au service de nos
concitoyens encore faut-il que ceux qui
assurent cette sécurité pour nos
concitoyens puissent le faire dans des
conditions de travail convenable le
déplacement de pierre bédier s'est
terminée par la visite de la ferme d'or
sanglés une exploitation spécialisée
dans la pomme de terre qui fournit les
cantines des collèges du département